what is this brief mortal life
if not the pursuit of legacy
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this video
let's have a look ahead at next week's
episode well my friends after watching
HBO's official video for episode 7 of
House of the Dragon it looks like
everything is about to go up in Flames
as the [ __ ] hits the fan now let's get
into this video because it looks like
there's a lot of very interesting things
happening in The Following episode in
HBO's new official video it opens up
with everyone on driftmark the home of
House of valerion during lady Elena
valerion's funeral ceremony as you all
know we saw lady Elena valerion die by
Dragonfire in the most recent episode
and I must say that was one of the most
heartbreaking moments from the Season
watching lady Lena ask her own dragon
Veigar to burn her and her baby alive
was awful now I certainly understand why
she did it because she knew her and her
unborn daughter would not survive anyway
we also heard lady Lena say she wanted
to die the death of a dragon rider so it
was fitting in her own way however hard
it may have been to watch now there was
one little thing I really did love and
that was how vegar hesitated not wanting
to actually burn her own Rider now that
lady Lena valerion is gone she was
brought back home for an official burial
ceremony at Sea we do see her
sarcophagus get dropped into the water
as everyone stands there in silence
Damon has now lost a second wife leaving
him open to find another this is
interesting because renera has now lost
her lover as well since her Harwin died
in the fire at his home of harrenhal
this now leaves renera open to find
herself another match of her own I do
believe we will see renera and Damon
begin their love affair very soon we
have seen glimpses of this in some of
HBO's other official photos like this
one right here it seems likely that
Damon and renera may get married in the
future but we shall see what they do
with them after this now that lady Lena
valerion is dead this also means someone
will Mount her Dragon Veigar which is
something we will see in The Following
episode Damon and Lady Lena's daughter
will most likely want vegar for herself
as sort of a way to to honor her mother
but as you saw in the video someone
steals vegar at night right after the
funeral ceremony viserys Ian Allison's
second born son Amon Targaryen will
mount vagar for himself eager to get a
dragon himself he will make vegar his
Dragon right under everyone else's nose
a lot of different things will unfold
during this scene in George R Martin's
novel Fire and Blood we learned that
this will lead to a fight in which aemon
loses his eye shortly after viserys
reminds Amon that he still doesn't have
his own dragon it upsets him leading him
to searching for a dragon in secret as
aemon is looking to mount vegar
raniera's youngest son Joffrey sees him
doing it so as a way to make sure
Joffrey doesn't say anything aemon slaps
him then threatens him when Joffrey
begin to yell this is when aemon gets on
vegar's back and flies in a few circles
before landing the dragon by then
however Joffrey had already said what
happened to his older brothers jacaris
and lucari's valerion the four boys then
begin fighting with the wooden swords
and aemon yells out the name strong
suggesting that they're all bastards now
since jacaris was the oldest he did
understand what this insult meant so he
began fighting aemond again when aemon
eventually gains the upper hand he
starts beating Jacari savagely however
that's when Lou carries draws his dagger
and slashes at eamon's face removing his
eye after the incident Allison wants
Justice she wants an eye for an eye
however viserys refuses to do so you can
see the aftermath right here as you can
see renira's son has blood all over his
face after the fight this is when we
will most likely see Allison run at
renera with the Valyrian steel dagger in
her hand we even see Rainier's hand as
bleeding most likely from the dagger
during the attack this is when renera
says now they see you as you are renera
feels this is how Allison has been for a
while now everyone there should know how
Allison really feels about renero I mean
it's already no secret their friendship
has been over like we saw in the last
episode Alison knows renira's sons are
bastards and she doesn't want any of
them are sending the Iron Throne before
her own Sons Alice and will now have a
lot of assistance in making sure that
never happens because her father Serrato
will be back in the capital as the hand
of the king thanks to Lara strong
viserys needs a new hand therefore Otto
will get his old job back we do see he
is now wearing the badge once again and
now that our father is back she will
have all the help she needs with
exposing rhaenera in her bastard Sons
unfortunately for renera she will be
living on Dragonstone one [ __ ] really
hits the fan I do wonder if Damon will
be staying there with her from here on
out we see how close he is to renera
already and since he's never really
welcome at King's Landing he might stay
there when he gets back to Westeros in
fact we might even see Damon and ranera
arrange marriages with their own
children since Alison doesn't want her
daughter Helena marrying renera's
illegitimate son it would make sense for
Damon's daughters to marry reniro's Sons
now another thing we should see is Sir
Lenor valerion fight with his friend
Carl Corey we saw glimpses of this in
HBO's first ever official trailer for
House of the Dragon if you remember we
saw sir lanor fighting someone inside of
his home on driftmark in George RR
Martin's Fire and Blood Lenore is slain
by his own friend as a matter of fact
mushroom says it was set up by and done
on behalf of Damon Targaryen maybe Damon
does this as a way to get rid of
Rainier's husband once and for all now
if this does happen it would be slightly
different than how George R Martin wrote
it because Lenor dies in spicetown not
on driftmark in AIM on mounts vagar
after lanar's funeral not Lena's either
way regardless of how it happens the
ending would be the same I guess if they
did things slightly out of order it
wouldn't be that big of a deal aemon
would still be losing his eye and
getting vegar Allison would still want
Justice Damon loses another wife and Sir
Lenor dies so things are still happening
basically as they should so as you can
see the next episode will have a lot of
very interesting and exciting things
unfolding the blacks and the grains are
now becoming an Unstoppable Force that's
about the made an immovable object when
they eventually slam into each other
there will be fireworks that you won't
want to miss make sure you subscribe so
you can be the first to see all of my
other new videos I will be releasing
this week there's so much more heading
your way now let me know your thoughts
on everything that's happening in The
Following episode do you agree with what
I said or is there something I'm missing
let me know down below and as always I
want to thank everyone for watching I
hope all of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign